The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So over
the last lecture,
we have talked about
coherence within an atom,
coherence between two levels,
coherence between three levels.
And today, in the
last class, we want
to talk about coherence
between atoms.
So this is now, I think,
for the first time
in this course that we really
have more than one atom.
Well, maybe we discussed
some collision or broadening,
or we discussed [INAUDIBLE]
interaction between two atoms.
But usually, atomic physics
is one atom at a time.
But now we want to understand
one important phenomenon which
happens when we have many atoms.
And the phenomenon is
called superradiance.
So I left something
good for the end.
And superradiance has
in common the word
super with superconductivity
and superfluidity.
And it really represents
that the atom, many atoms
act together.
And the word super
also means coherence
among atoms-- superfluidity
and superconductivity
have macroscopic wave function
where all the atoms, the meta
waves are coherent.
The phenomenon of
superradiance, as we will see,
has not so much to do
with coherent atoms.
It has more to do
with coherent photons.
So it's more-- some people
regard superradiance as a laser
without mirrors.
But you'll see where
the story leads us to.
So just to set the
stage-- for many atoms,
we should first talk
about single atoms.
And all that is described
in this landmark paper
by [INAUDIBLE] in 1954, which
is posted on our website.
So if you have a single atom
prepared in the excited state,
it decays to the
ground state, and we
want to characterize the
system by emission rate
as a function of time.
So the emission rate initially
is gamma, the natural language
of the excited state.
And then, of course,
the emission rate
decays because we don't
have any atoms left.
Similarly, the probability
to be in the ground state
is zero initially, and then
with an exponential approach,
it eventually goes to
unity after a while,
after we have only atoms
in the gamma state.
So this is rather
straightforward.
But now we want to
bring in a second atom.
And I'm asking,
what happens when
we have not the one
atom, but two atoms?
One is in the ground state.
One is excited.
So pretty much what we have
added to the original situation
with one excited atom
was we've brought in one
ground state atom, which naively
you would think does nothing.
But that's not the case.
What happens is-- and I
assume just for review--
we will drop the
assumption later,
but we assume for now
that all the atoms
are within one
optical wavelength.
What we then realize
is for two atoms--
and I will show you that
in its full beauty--
that the initial rate of light
which comes out of the system
is the same.
So the extra ground
state atom does not
change the initial emission
rate, but it goes down faster.
And if we ask what is the
probability that the atom is
in the ground state, we find
that it's only one half.
So in other words, normalized
[INAUDIBLE] system,
we have a ground and excited
state atom, and what comes out
is only half a photon.
Half of the atoms do not decay.
So it's not the same
rate and the same decay.
Something profoundly
has happened.
And this is what you
want to understand.
So let me give you
the correct answer.
The rate of emission
is a function
of time for this situation.
We start out with gamma, but
then the emission decays, not
with gamma but with 2 gamma.
And the probability that both
atoms are in the ground state--
or that the second atom, so to
speak, is in the ground state--
will only asymptotically
go to 1/2.
And it does so
exponentially-- but again,
with the time constant,
which is two times faster
than for the single-atom system.
So we have the same initial
emission rate, but only
probability of 1/2
to emit at all.
So in order to
understand it, we have
to look at an atom in the
excited state and atom
in the ground state.
And we want to write
down the wave function
as a superposition of a
symmetrized and antisymmetrized
wave function.
I should tell you, I'm going
very slowly for two atoms.
And then once I've introduced
the concept for two atoms,
with a few pen strokes, we can
immediately discuss in atoms.
So all the phsyics,
all the understanding
what goes on in
superradiance is already
displayed for two atoms.
So we want to have
a superposition
of symmetric and
antisymmetric wave function.
The symmetric one is a
normalized wave function
which is ge plus eg.
And we call that the
superradiant wave function,
for reasons which will
become clear in a moment.
And if you have a
minus sign here,
the antisymmetric
combination, we
call this subradiant
wave function.
Now, what happens is,
we have to consider--
so we have symmetrized
the wave function.
Well, I didn't
really tell you why,
but it's always
good to symmetrize.
Symmetry is, if you can
use it, something good.
And the reason why I
symmetrized it is because I want
look at the interaction
Hamiltonian.
And if I look at the interaction
Hamiltonian-- the one
we have seen many, many
times but now for two atoms--
we will immediately realize that
this interaction Hamiltonian is
symmetric.
So therefore, if the
Hamiltonian is symmetric,
it's a really good
starting point
to have the wave function
for the atoms expanded
in a symmetric basis.
And since I want to emphasize
that the whole story I'm
telling you today
has nothing to do
with the kind of
second quantization--
it is about
spontaneous emission,
but it's not
involving any subtlety
of spontaneous
emission and field
quantization-- I want to
write down the interaction
Hamiltonian both in a classical
and a quantum mechanical way.
In the classical way, we
have the dipole moment d1.
We have the dipole moment d2.
And the atoms talk to the
electric field at position RNT.
And now you realize where
some of the assumptions
are important, since the
atoms are localized to
within a wavelength,
they rarely talk
to the same electric field.
There are no phase factors.
In about 55 minutes or so,
we introduce phase factors
for extended samples.
But for now, we don't.
And therefore, what
the atoms couple with
is with a dipole
moment, which is
a sum of the two dipole moments.
So this is classical
or semi-classical.
So what enters in
the Hamiltonian
is only the sum of the
operators for the two atoms.
And the same happens
in the QED Hamiltonian.
And actually, I will get
a little bit more mileage
out of the QED Hamiltonian,
as you will see in a moment.
Because with the QED Hamiltonian
we describe the atomic system--
so at first atom
one-- with the raising
and lowering operator
with the atoms interacting
with a and a [INAUDIBLE].
And then I have to add the term
where the index one and two are
exchanged.
So we are introducing
here-- that's
convenient for two-level atom--
the spin notation sigma plus
and sigma minus are the
raising and lowering operator
which flip the atom from the
ground to the excited state
and vice versa.
But the important
part now is-- and this
is where, actually, everything
comes from in superradiance--
that the coupling involves
not the individual spins,
little sigma plus,
sigma 1 and sigma 2--
it only involves the
sum of the individuals.
i equals 122, and later
we extend the sum to n.
So therefore, what matters
for the interaction
of the atoms with the
electromagnetic field
is the sum of all the
atomic spin operators.
And the sum is, of course,
symmetric against exchange.
So therefore, when
we are asking what
is the coupling of the
state which I called
the superradiant state, the
one where we had symmetrized eg
plus ge, or we ask,
what is the coupling
of the subradiant state
to-- well, the state where
both atoms are in
the ground state.
Well, now we can use symmetry.
The left-hand side is symmetric.
The operator is symmetric.
And now only the symmetric
state will couple.
The antisymmetric
state will not couple.
So therefore, the subradiant
state, eg minus ge,
cannot decay.
That's why we call
it subradiant.
I think a better word
would be non-radiant,
but non is definitely
subradiant.
And for the matrix
element eg and ge,
we find that we have actually
an enhancement of the coupling
by a factor of square root 2.
So now we pretty much
know what we have to do.
You want to use the symmetry
of-- let's assume we consider
ground and excited state
of each atom as spin 1/2.
But now we want to look at the
total spin, the total pseudo
angular momentum
of the two atoms,
and later we extend
it to n atoms.
So we want to use now the
power of the angular momentum
description.
And that goes like follows.
We have four states
of two atoms.
And this is gg, ge, eg, and ee.
And if I denote with
ground state spin
down, excited state spin
up, I'm talking about 2
spin 1/2 states.
And 2 spin 1/2 states
can couple to s
equals 1, total s equals 1,
and total spin s equals 0.
And that's what I've done here.
I've arranged the states ee, the
symmetric superradiant state,
the ground state, and
the subradiant state.
A variation energy
level diagram--
here we have 0
excitation energy,
here we have 1
and here we have two excitations
energies of the atom.
But I've also labeled
now the spin labels
for the combined system.
Those symmetrized states
correspond to a spin equals 1.
It's a triplet letter with
three different magnetic quantum
numbers.
m equals plus 1 means
everything is highly excited.
m equals minus 1 means we are
in the total ground state.
And here we have
the simulate state,
which is the antisymmetric
state or the subradiant state.
And our interaction Hamiltonian
is the total spin plus minus.
It is the raising and
the lowering operator.
And you know that the
raising and lowering
operator for the spin is
only making transitions
within a manifold of total s.
It just changes the end
quantum number by plus minus 1.
So the Hamiltonian cannot do
anything to the simulate state,
because there is no other
simulate state to couple.
But within the triplet
manifold, the sigma plus sigma
minus operator is
creating transitions
between the
different end states.
And the coupling constant,
which for an individual atom
was little g is now factor
of square root 2 enhanced.
And we will see in a few
minutes, that for n atoms,
it's square root n enhanced.
And if any speak, that's where
the word super in superradiance
comes from.
Yeah, actually let
me just quickly add
the diagram for the single atom.
The single atom has only an
excited state, a ground state.
It corresponds to s equals 1/2.
And we have magnetic
quantum numbers off plus 1/2
and minus 1/2.
And the coupling due to
the light atom interaction
goes with the
coupling constant g.
So the key message
we have learned here
is that when we
have several atoms
within an optical
wavelength, we should
use for their
description symmetrized
and antisymmetrized states.
Or when we generalize
to more than two atoms,
we should just add the
total angular momenta
by treating each atom
as pseudo spin 1/2.
And it is this
angular classification
which tells us how the
radiation proceeds.
Because the coupling to
the electromagnetic field
is only involving the
lowering and raising
operators for the total spin.
And this only acts
on a manifold where
the total spin s is conserved.
And what we get is transitions
with delta in plus minus 1.
So the question, have those
effects been observed?
Yes, they have, actually.
And they're important
for a lot of research.
But just for two atoms,
the simplest observation
is when you take
two atoms-- let's
say two sodium atoms--
bring them very close,
and you form a
sodium 2 molecule.
And to some extent, in four
states where the molecule are
binding is not
completely changing
the electronic structure, we
can regard the sodium 2 molecule
as consisting of
two sodium atoms.
And indeed, if you do
spectroscopy of the sodium 2
molecule, you find
some molecular states
which are very long lived, like
the subradiant states, which
do not radiate at
all, but then you
find states which have a
spontaneous emission rate which
is about two times faster than
the spontaneous emission rate.
So you find that
you can understand
some radiative
properties of molecules
by assuming that they
are related to the sub
and superradiant
state of the two atoms
which form this molecule.
So an example here
is sodium 2 molecule.
A state where the gamma molecule
is approximately 2 times gamma
sodium, or other states
where it's very small.
OK.
Now we understand the basic four
of superradiance in two atoms.
And therefore, we can now
generalize it to end particles.
But before I use the
spin algebra to describe
end particles, I want to glean
some intuition where we just
consider-- and
this takes us back
to the beginning of the
course-- where we consider
end spins in a magnetic field.
And I really invite you to think
now completely classically.
We'll describe it quantum
mechanically in a moment.
But I've often said
in this course,
if in doubt, if you have
a classical description
and a quantum mechanical
and they seem to contradict,
usually there is more truth
in the classical description.
It's so much easier
to fool yourself
with the formalism
of quantum mechanics.
So let's take end spins
in a magnetic field
and ask what happens.
So we have end spins.
So these are now real spins.
They have a real
magnetic moment.
These are tiny
little bar magnets.
And we do pi over 2 pulse.
And after we've done
a pi over 2 products,
the spins are aligned like this.
Let's assume we had
our magnetic field.
And now what happens
is these spins
will precess at the
line of frequency.
So now you have your end spins.
They precess together.
And if you have a magnetic
moment which oscillates,
the classical equation
of electromagnetism
tells you that you have now
a system which radiates.
But compared to a single
atom, the dipole moment
is now n times the single
atom dipole moment.
So therefore, what do we
expect for the radiated power?
Well, if the
electromagnetic radiation
by an oscillating electric or
an oscillating magnetic dipole
moment scales with a
dipole moment squared,
therefore, we would expect
that the power radiated
is proportional to n squared.
And that means I have to take
the perfect of n [INAUDIBLE].
This means this is n times
higher than if you assume
you have n individual
particles, and each of them
emits electromagnetic radiation.
what I'm telling you
is if you scatter
n spins through your
laboratory, you excite them.
Pi over 2 pulse, they radiate.
They radiate a power
which is proportion to n.
But if you put them all
together, localize them better
than the wavelengths,
their radiated power
is proportional to n
square, which is an n times
enhancement.
So the way how I
put it for n spins--
and this is a situation of
nuclear magnetic resonance--
this is the completely
natural picture.
But if I would have asked
you the question-- let's
take n atoms which are excited
and put them close together,
you say, well, each atom
does spontaneous emission,
and if you have n atoms,
we get n times c intensity
you would have gotten
a different result.
So we are so accustomed
to look at spins in NMR
as a coherent system, look
that all the spins add up
to one giant antenna, to
one giant oscillating dipole
moment, whereas for
atoms, we are so much used
to saying each atom is
its own particle and thus
its own thing.
So for n excited
atoms, they are usually
regarded as independent.
However-- and this is
the message of today--
there shouldn't be a difference.
All 2 level systems
are equivalent.
Side remark-- for NMR in
spins, it is much, much easier
to observe the effect,
because the condition
that all the spins are
localized within one wavelength
is always fulfilled
if the wavelength is
meter or kilometers.
But if you have
atoms which radiate
at the optical wavelengths, this
condition becomes nontrivial.
That is partially responsible
for the misconception
that you treat the
two-level system which
is a spin in your
head differently
from the two-level
system which is an atom.
So the important
difference here is lambda.
And we have to compare
it with a sample size.
And usually, the sample
size is much larger
in the optical domain,
and is much, much smaller
in the NMR domain.
However-- and that's
what we'll see
during the remainder
of this class--
some of the dramatic
consequences of superradiance
will even survive under
suitable conditions
in the extended samples.
So when we have samples
of excited atoms much,
much larger than the
optical wavelengths,
we can still observe
superradiance.
So therefore, for
pedagogical reasons,
I first complete the
focus on the case
that everything is
tightly localized.
We derive some
interesting equations,
and then we see how
they are modified
when we go to extended samples.
But I want to say, the
intuition from spin systems,
the intuition from
classical precession
and nuclear magnetic
resonance, will help us
what happens for
electronically excited atoms.
So we want to use
this other spin 1/2
system as a powerful
analogy to guide us.
So before I start with the
angular momentum formalism,
I want to emphasize that what
are the ingredients here.
Well, we're talking about
coherence-- coherent radiation,
coherence between atoms-- and
we'll talk about radiation.
And the important part
here is the following.
That when we talk
about radiation,
we have the situation
that all atoms interact
with a common radiation field.
In other words, all the
spins, all the atoms
have to emit their
photons into the same mode
of the electromagnetic field.
And therefore, you may
be right in some limit
that the atoms are independent,
but not the photons they emit.
They go into the same mode.
And therefore, the emitted
photons cannot be treated
independently.
And that's why the
classical picture
is so powerful for that.
Because in the
classic picture, we
do a coherent summation
of the field amplitudes.
So we have constructive
interference.
The superposition principle
of field amplitudes
build into our equations and
deeply engraved in our brains.
And that's why when we
use classical arguments,
we automatically account for
that the photons interfere,
that the photons are
emitted into the same mode
of the electromagnetic field.
And eventually, this
leads to the phenomenon
that we have coherence
and enhancement when
we look at spontaneous
emission for n atoms
which are sufficiently
localized.
So let me also discuss
what we have assumed here.
Number one is, we
have assumed we
have a localization
of the sample
smaller than the
optical wavelengths.
The other thing-- and
this is really important--
we are talking here about
a collective phenomenon
where n atoms act
together and do something.
They develop the phenomenon
of superradiance.
They decay much, much faster
than any individual atom could
do by itself.
But nevertheless, we have not
assumed-- or we have actually
excluded in our
description-- that there
is any direct interaction
between the atoms.
The atoms have no
[INAUDIBLE] interaction.
They're not forming molecules.
They're not part of a solid
with shared electrons.
The atoms are, in that
sense, non-interacting.
And therefore, in
a way, as long as
they are just
atoms, independent.
Finally-- and I want
you to think about it--
you can think about
already for two atoms
before we generalize
it to n atoms.
Think about it.
What was really the
assumption about the atoms?
Do the atoms have to be bosons
to be in this symmetric state?
Can they be fermions?
Or can they be even
distinguishable particles?
If the two atoms where
one would be a sodium atom
and one would be a rubidium
atom-- but let's just
say we live in a world where
sodium and rubidium atoms emit
exactly the same color of light.
Would we have been sub
and superradiant state
for two atoms, one of which
is sodium and one of which
is rubidium?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And that confuses many people.
It is the indistinguishability
of the photons
they have emitted.
It is the common mode where
the photons are emitted.
The atoms can be distinguished.
Also, we've made the assumption
that the atoms are localized to
within an area which is
much smaller than lambda.
But you could imagine you
have a solid state matrix
and you have one atom
here, one atom there,
and you can go with a
microscope and distinguish them.
So therefore, the moment
you can distinguish them
because they are pinned
down in a lattice--
or if you don't like a lattice,
take two microscopic ion traps
a few nanometers
apart, and you tightly
hold onto two ions--
it doesn't matter
whether they are
bosons or fermions.
It only matters whether
your bosons or fermions
when the atomic wave
functions overlap
and you have to symmatrize it.
As long as you have two atoms
which are spatially separated,
it doesn't matter whether
they are bosons or fermions.
And that also means they can
be completely different atoms.
You can already
call the Boson A,
Boson B. Now you can call
it sodium and rubidium,
and they can have different
numbers of nucleus.
They can be different numbers
of neutrons in the nucleus.
It could be different
isotopes of the same atom.
The whole collective
phenomenon comes
when they emit a photon
into the same mode.
OK.
So now we want to
treat to a formula
treatment for end particles.
So we have now the individual
pseudo spins one half.
We perform now with some
overall end particles.
We get the total spin s.
The total spin s
quantum number has
to be smaller or
equal to n over 2,
because we have m
spin 1/2 systems.
The end quantum
number is 1/2 times
the difference of
the atoms which
are in the excited state
minus the atoms which
are in the ground state.
And this is, of course, trivial.
Trivially must be
smaller than s.
Because m is this
z component of s.
And we are now
describing the system
by the eigenstates s and
n of the collective spin.
So that means we have
the following situation.
We have a manifold-- we want to
show now all the energy levels.
We have a manifold which
has a maximum spin n over 2.
The next manifold
has n over 2 minus 1.
And the last one
has-- let's assume
we have an odd number of
particles-- x equals 1/2.
So here, we have
now n energy levels.
We can go from all
the n atoms excited
to all the n atoms
being de-excited.
In the following manifold,
we have s is one less.
And therefore, we have
a letter of states
which is a little bit shorter.
And eventually,
for s equals 1/2,
we have only two components
plus 1/2 and minus 1/2.
So those levels interact with
the electromagnetic field.
The operator of the
electromagnetic field,
we have already
derived that, involves
the sum of all of the little
sigma pluses, sigma i pluses,
and we call the sum of all
of them s plus and s minus.
And the matrix element is
now for spontaneous emission.
You have a state with sm.
s minus is the lowering operator
for the n particle system,
so it goes from a state
with a certain number
of atomic excitations
to one excitation less,
and that means this is the
act of emitting spontaneously
one photon.
The operator s minus stays
within the s manifold,
so we state in the
same letter, which
is characterized by
the quantum number s.
But we lower the end
quantum number by one.
The end quantum
number is a measure
of the number of excitations.
And we know from
general spin algebra
that this matrix element is s
minus m plus 1 times s plus n.
There are, of
course, pre-factors
like the dipole matrix
element of a single atom.
But I always want to normalize
things to a single atom.
And by just using
the square root,
if you have a single particle,
which is in the s to m
equals 1/2 state, then you
see that it this square root
is just 1.
So therefore, for when I discuss
now the relative strengths
of the transitions
between those eigenstates,
I've always normalized
to a single particle.
For a single particle, the
transition matrix element is 1.
OK.
So therefore, what we
want to discuss now is,
we want to discuss
the rate, which
is the matrix element
squared, or the intensity
of the observed radiation
relative to a single particle.
So the intensity-- and this
is what we are talking about--
is now the square root of the
square root, or the square
of the square root, which is s
minus 1 plus m times s plus m.
Pretty much, this is
the complete description
of superradiance for
strongly localized atoms.
It's all in this one formula.
Once we learned how to
classify the states,
we can just borrow
all the results
from angular momentum, addition,
and angular momentum operators.
So I want to use this
formula for the intensity
and look at which is the most
superradiant state, the state
where all the particles
are symmetric.
And this is a
state with s equals
n where the spin is n over 2.
So I'm looking now at
the letter of m states,
and I want to figure
out what happens.
So the maximum m
state is m equals s,
all the atoms are excited.
And now the first
photon gets emitted.
So just put s equals m equals
n half into the formula
for the intensity, and you find
that the intensity gives us
this expression is just n.
So we have n excited
atoms, and they initially
emit with an
intensity which is n.
And this is the same as for n
completely independent atoms.
So nothing really special
to write home about.
But now we should go
further down the ladder,
and let's look at the state
which has m equals zero.
Well, then the intensity
of the matrix element
squared for the transition,
which goes to m equals zero,
has an intensity
which is n over 2.
I will just look. s is
n over 2, and m is zero.
So we have the
question whether we
have odd or even
number of particles,
but it doesn't really matter.
What dominates is always
the big factor n over 2.
So what we find
out is that we have
an enhancement, huge enhancement
over independent atom,
because this intensity
goes with n squared,
and this proportionality
to n squared,
this is a hallmark
of superradiance.
So this is what
is characteristic
for superradiance.
We have an n times enhancement
relative to the a singular
atom.
So this is one important aspect.
Now, in the classical
picture, that
should come very naturally.
If you have all
the spins aligned
and they start the
[INAUDIBLE] procession,
there is not a lot of
oscillating dipole moment.
But when half of the
spins are de-excited,
they are now in the XY plane.
Now you have this giant antenna
which oscillates and radiates.
So it's clear that
at the beginning,
the effect is less pronounced,
and if you're halfway
down the Bloch sphere, then
you would expect this n times
enhancement.
But now let's go
further down the ladder
and ask what happens when
we arrive at the end.
So I'm asking now, what
is the intensity when
the last photon gets emitted.
There is only one
excitation in the system.
And the answer is, it's not
one like an independent atom.
If you inspect the square root
expression, you find it's n.
So we have one
excitation in the system,
but it's completely symmetrized.
And therefore, we have
an n times enhancement.
And I want to show you
where it comes about.
So there's only one
particle excited.
And here, we have an
n times enhancement.
By the way, the states with
the classification s and m
are called the
[INAUDIBLE] state.
And this state here, which
has a single excitation
but it radiates n times
faster than a single atom,
is a very special
[INAUDIBLE] state.
And there is currently an effort
in Professor [INAUDIBLE] lab
to realize in a very
well-controlled way
this special [INAUDIBLE]
state in the laboratory.
There are non-classical
states, because they're not
behaving as you would
maybe naturally assume
a system with a single
excitation to behave.
So let's maybe try to
shed some light on it.
One way how you can intuitively
understand superradiance
is really with a
classical antenna picture
that you have n spins which
form a microscopic dipole
moment which oscillates.
And this is a very nice picture
to understand the n times
enhancement when we
have half of the atoms
excited and the other
half de-excited.
Let me now give
you a nice argument
which explains why a single
excitation in this system
now leads to an n
times enhanced decay.
The situation is that
the initial state
for this last photon is,
we have an excited atom,
and all the atoms are
in the ground state.
However, we could also
have in this nomenclature
the second atom excited.
Or we could have the third
one excited, and so on.
So therefore, what we
have is-- because we
are in the left-most [INAUDIBLE]
which has the maximum s spin
quantum number of n
over 2, that means
everything is fully symmetrized.
So therefore, we have
to fully symmetrize
by summing over the
n possibilities.
And our final state is, of
course, the fully symmetrized
[INAUDIBLE] state.
And now you realize
that you have
a coherent summation over--
you have n contributions.
So therefore, the matrix
element has n contributions
compared to single atom.
The normalization is
only square root n.
So therefore, the matrix element
is square root n times larger
than for an individual atom.
So by simply having
one atom excited and n
minus 1 atom not
excited, but if you now
have the fully
symmetrized state,
you don't know for fundamental
reasons which atom is excited.
You have a superposition
state where the excitation
can be with either of the atom.
This state, which has a
similar quantum of excitation,
radiates n times faster
than a single atom would.
Let me make a side remark.
Maybe some of you remember when
we went to [INAUDIBLE] QED,
we had just proudly quantized
the electromagnetic field,
and we discussed the
vacuum Rabi splitting.
And I told you that the
vacuum Rabi splitting
is if the cavity is not empty
but is filled with n atoms,
because of the matrix element
of the a dagger operator,
you get an enhancement of the
vacuum Rabi splitting, which
is square root n,
then photon number.
But then I showed you the
important first observation,
the pioneering research at Cal
Tech by JF Kimball and Gerhard
Rempe, and they didn't
vary the photon number.
They varied the atom number.
And when they had more
flux in the atomic beam,
the Rabi splitting
became larger and larger.
Well, we've just
learned that when
we have n atoms, that the matrix
element for emitting the photon
is square root n times enhanced.
So if you put n atoms in a
cavity filled with little n
photons, the Rabi splitting
between the two modes
has square root n plus
1 in the photon number
and square root big
n in the atom number.
So the effect I've shown you in
the demonstration of the vacuum
Rabi splitting is this
scaling with the atom number.
This actually can be understood
as a superradiant effect.
OK.
So that's pretty
much what I wanted
to tell you about the basic
phenomenon of superradiance.
Now I want to discuss
two more things.
One is superradiance
in an extended sample.
Ad we have time for that.
But I also want to discuss
with you the question.
Let's assume we have
the same system,
and we just convinced ourselves,
yes, it's superradiant.
Photons are emitted
n times faster.
Now, what would you think
will happen when we are not
looking for
spontaneous emission,
but we shine a
laser light on it,
and we are asking
for induced emission?
Or the other way
around-- we ask--
and you know that from
Einstein's treatment,
it's completely
recipocal-- where
we are asking the question,
what happens to the absorption
process?
So is a stimulated emission
process or an absorption
process, are they
also enhanced n times?
I don't know.
Do you have any
opinions about that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's a subtle way of counting.
I've shown you that certain
matrix element-- especially
the matrix element when
the spin is in the middle,
is at 90 degrees-- that we
have matrix elements which
are n times enhanced.
And of course, if you ask
for absorption or stimulated
emission, we are talking to
a system which has an n times
enhanced matrix element.
And you would say,
things go n times faster.
Why don't you hold this
thought for a moment?
Now let me just wear
another hat and let
me say that we have assumed
that we have n independent
spins that are closely
next to each other,
but they're not interacting.
And now I take these n spins,
and for stimulated emission
and absorption, we can just use
a picture of Rabi oscillation.
On the first Rabi
cycle, we emit.
On the next Rabi
cycle, we absorb.
So if I take now--
and why don't you
think not about these
pseudo spins electronically,
atoms with [INAUDIBLE]
excitation--
just think of real spins
which have a magnetic moment,
and you drive them to
the magnetic field.
So now you have
your n little spins.
You apply a magnetic
field to them,
time-dependent
magnetic field, and
the time-dependent
magnetic field
is now driving the spin
in Rabi oscillations.
And the external drive
field talks to one spin,
talks to the next,
talks to all of them.
But each of the
spins does exactly
the same Rabi oscillation it
would do if all the other atoms
where not present.
So the picture is, you
have an external field.
All the atoms couple
to the external field.
But the coupling of each
atom to this external field
is exactly the same
as of a single atom
coupling to the external field.
And the Rabi frequency
for each atom
is exactly the
Rabi frequency you
would get for a single atom.
So therefore, based
on this picture,
I would expect that
I have my end spins,
and these can now be real
spins with a magnetic moment,
or can be atoms in the
electronically excited state.
I coherently drive them
with a drive field,
and they will do
Rabi oscillations.
But the frequency
or Rabi oscillations
will be the same as
for a single atom.
OK.
We've just held the
thought that their matrix
elements in the Dickey
states, which are square root
n times larger, and
the Dickey state
seem to suggest
something to us which
would say there should
be an enhancement,
whereas the analysis
in independent atoms,
which are driven by an external
field, also seems compelling.
So now we have to reconcile
the two approaches.
Is the question clear?
We want to figure out-- we have
matrix elements in the Dickey
state which suggest enhancement,
but the simple picture
of n independent atoms
driven by an external field
would say there
is no enhancement.
OK.
So let me just write down more
formally what I explained.
When we have an initial
state, which is all the atoms
are in the ground
state to the power n,
and the state n
would evolve when
it is driven in
a state phi of t,
so now the exact wave
function for our n particles
is nothing else than the
time-dependent solution
of Schrodinger's equation
for the single particle.
So this is single
particle to the power n.
So therefore, this is pretty
much a mathematical proof
unless I've made a
mistake, which I haven't.
So it takes exactly half
a single atom Rabi period
to completely invert
the population exactly
s for a single atom.
So that's the result.
However, if you describe
the system by Dickie states,
you have matrix element which
are matrix elements which
are proportional to n.
However, if you want to--
I've described it just
as a two-level system.
Each atom does Rabi oscillation.
I've said, OK, the
system of n atoms
is just n individual systems.
But if you insist to describe
it as a collective spin,
then we have the Dickie states.
Then we have the n
times enhancement
of the matrix element.
But then we also have
to go through n states.
So we have n steps in
the Dickie letter ladder.
And one can say now-- and
this is the exact argument--
you have n steps.
You take each step
n times faster,
but the total time is the same.
So n times 1 over n is 1.
OK.
But now when we talk about
spontaneous emission,
we are not driving the system
with an external field.
It's really driven by the system
itself, which emits photons
into the empty mode.
Spontaneous emission,
each step is
proportional to the
matrix element squared,
because we're talking
about [INAUDIBLE]
spontaneous emission.
So this is proportional
to n square.
And if you say that
we have n steps,
well, then we have
n squared over n.
Then we have a speed up.
Each step is n squared faster.
We divide by n, and we
get the superradiant speed
of which is n.
So superradiance is something
that you observe in spontaneous
emission, but you cannot
absorb it in a driven system.
Because in a driven
system, you can
say you have a classical
external field.
And this external
talks to one atom,
to n atoms exactly
in the same way.
It is really the interference
of spontaneously emitted photons
which is at the heart
of superradiance.
As a side remark,
we are talking here
about coherent effect,
which is n times enhanced.
And you can actually
regard that as a kind
of bosonic enhancement in
the emission of photons,
because the photons are bosons.
When Bose-Einstein
condensation was discovered
and people were thinking about
basic experiments, of course,
one thing which
was on our mind is,
we wanted to show that
there are processes
in the Bose-Einstein condensate
we are n times enhanced.
For fermions, they
would be suppressed.
This is the flip side.
Big enhancements for
bosons, complete suppression
for fermions.
And we found that, for instance,
the formation of the condensate
had an n times enhancement.
There was a stimulation factor.
But we also thought you
should actually-- there may
be ways where you can observe
suppression of light scattering
or enhancement of
light scattering.
But we thought about it with
two laser beam [INAUDIBLE]
scattering, and the
idea seemed compelling.
And then we said,
no, wait a moment.
If you use laser beams,
everything is stimulated.
You can observe
bosonic enhancement
and fermeonic
suppression only when
you have spontaneous events.
If you drive it in a
unitary time evolution,
you will not be able to see
quantum statistical suppression
or enhancement.
And the same thing as
we have seen here--
when you have a
stimulated system,
everything is undergoing
a unitary time evolution,
and the unitary time
evolution for n atoms
is the same as
for a single atom.
You need the element of
spontaneous emission.
So I'm not proving it
to you, but I'm just
making as a remark--
what we have seen here,
that the superradiance
only shows up
in spontaneous emission
and not when we drive
the system-- a driven system
is a unitary evolution.
And the same conclusion which
we just got for superradiance
also applies if you want to
observe fermionic suppression
or pulsonic enhancement
in quantum gases.
It needs an element of
spontaneous scattering
or spontaneous emission.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If we think of
it in terms of interference
of photons, how does
that tie in here?
Because if the stimulated
[INAUDIBLE] photons are still
interfering, then you can
get emission [INAUDIBLE].
PROFFESOR: The
quick answer is, you
have a classical field which
you use for-- you have a laser
field for stimulate
emission for absorption.
There are so many photons
in the laser field
that the few photons which your
system emits do not matter.
They are really talking
to a classical field,
and it doesn't matter whether
the other n minus 1 atoms
have emitted a photon, because
you have zillions of photons
in your laser field,
and they determine
the dynamics of the system.
OK.
Super radiance would
not be as important
as it is if it could not
observed in extended samples.
So now I want to use
the last 10 minutes
to show you what
is kept and what
has to be dropped when we
talk about extended samples.
So let's-- it doesn't
really matter,
but for pedagogical reasons,
let's assume we have
an extended sample
which is much,
much longer than the optical
wavelengths along the long axis
of the cigar and smaller
along the short axis.
The second condition
that the cigar
is smaller than along the long
axis does not really matter.
No, I'm not making
this assumption.
So it's a cigar, and
let's just assume
that everything is-- just saw
a contradiction in my notes.
So anyway, we have
now a system which
is-- let's have a Cuban
cigar, a really thick cigar.
And this is now our
extended sample.
And what I need is, I need the
cross section of the sample A.
And let's assume
the length is l.
This is diameter d.
It's a cigar much,
much larger than here.
And yes, we are talking
about superradiance,
we are talking about
spontaneous emission.
But if you see a long
cigar with excited atoms,
you think immediately
about lasing action.
The photon is emitted is
amplified along the path.
And of course, the
preferred direction
where you would expect the
maximum effect to happen
is when the light is
emitted along the long axis
of the cigar.
So you want to consider
now preferential modes
along the x-axis.
So if you now assume
that you have many atoms,
and they emit light, if an atom
here and here would emit light
in this direction, it may
constructively interfere.
But in another direction, it
will destructively interfere.
But let us now consider what is
the solid angle into which all
of the atoms can
coherently emit.
Well, you know that from
classical optics, the emission
into a solid angle of lambda
square over a can be coherent.
Sort of similar to when
you have a double slit
and you ask, over what angle
do the two slits emit inface.
You get a bright fringe,
and you get a dark fringe,
you get the next bright fringe.
The coherence, the angle
over which the pass lengths
differences do not add
up to more than lambda.
It's the deflection-limited
angle which for a beam of size
d is lambda over d.
And if you take it to
the second dimension,
the solid angle is lambda
squared over d squared.
So that's what
I'm talking about.
So if you would give all
the atoms in your assemble
just the right
phase that they are
coherent to emit
into the x-axis,
they will also coherently emit
into a small, solid angle,
and the solid angle is
given by this number.
So the just of it is--
and I will not completely
prove it to you, but I just
want to give you a taste--
is that therefore, we still
have a superradiant enhancement.
We know the superradiant
enhancement previously
when we had the
localized system was n.
But now we have the
n atoms act together,
but they're not acting together
for emission into 4 pi.
They are acting together for
emission into the solid angle.
And if I write the
big n as density
n times l times a squared,
the a squared cancels out
and I get n lambda square l.
And if you remember that
the cross section of an atom
was lambda square
for absorption,
if the atom is excited,
the cross section
for amplification of light
for stimulated emission
is also lambda squared.
So lambda squared is
the gain cross section.
And what we find now as a
superradiant enhancement factor
is nothing else like
something which reminds us
of a laser, which reminds
us of optical gain.
And actually, the
lasing phenomenon
in superradiance in extended
samples has a lot of analogies.
In some limits,
it's even identical.
When we are talking about
spontaneous emission,
we are not talking about
stimulated emission.
But if you have a system
which is in some excited state
superradiant Dickey
states, and we
are asking what are the
spontaneously emitted
photons coming out,
to say different atoms
emit into the same
mode, and now you
have to add up the
feeds coherently,
this is a language
we have used so far.
Or if you use a language atom
emits a photon and this photon
gets amplified on its way out,
those two language strongly
overlap or in some limits
are even identical.
So the amplification
of a photon on its way
out, this is behind
superradiance.
But when the localize the atoms
to lessen the wavelengths,
well, the atoms pretty
much emit as a whole
and there is no pass
lengths of the size
of the optical wavelengths
where you can say the photon
propagates, gets amplified.
So we have looked at just
what comes out of it.
But in extended
sample, you could even
address this situation.
How do the photons get
amplified, magnified,
augmented when they travel
from the center to the edge?
So you could actually ask,
what is the light intensity
as a function of the
position within the cigar?
For localized
samples, you can't.
So let me just write that down.
So this is analogous to
optical amplification
in an elongated,
inverted medium.
OK.
So you can formally
describe that.
You can now define new
Dickey states with respect
to the preferred mode.
And the preferred mode is
the mode in the x direction.
So what I've done is--
remember, we have those atoms.
Those atoms are now sitting at
different positions, x1 and x2.
And if I define
Dickey states which
have phase factors
into the ik x1,
into the ik x2, if now
this atom emits a photon
and this atom emits
a photon, well,
the second photon is x2
minus x1 ahead of this photon
if you think of those atoms
sitting aligned in a string.
But the phase vector is exactly
canceling the propagation phase
for the first atom in such
a way that if you are now
coupling these states to
the electromagnetic field,
the phase factors of the
electromagnetic field
in the mode cancel with
those phase factors,
and you again have the
situation that each state here
has an equal amplitude
for emission.
So now you have n
possible contributions,
and the normalization
is 1 over square root n,
and everything falls into place.
And you can define that for two
excited atoms with two phase
factors and so on.
So you can use immediately
the same formalism.
And what happens is those phase
factors for the interaction
Hamiltonian-- and
our interaction
Hamiltonian is now different.
It is di.
And now in an
extended sample, we
have to keep track of the
precision of the atom.
So for the coupling to the
mode in the x direction,
we have those phase factors.
So all the phase factors cancel.
And actually, I'm
not telling you
whether this is plus or
minus in order to cancel.
You pick the sign
that they all cancel,
and then you have superradiance.
You have fully
constructive interference.
Yes.
So all this looks now the
same as superradiance,
but there are also things
which are different,
and this is the following.
If the atom would emit now
photons, not in the preferred
mode, then-- remember,
we had the Dickey ladder.
We had the most superradiant
ladder, little bit
less superradiant
ladder, and eventually we
had the subradiant
ladder in order
of smaller and smaller
total quantum number s.
Emission in the preferred
mode stays in each letter,
and we have the
superradiant cascade.
But emission into
other modes is now
coupling different s states.
Because the operator or the
phase factor into the IKR
has broken to complete
permutation symmetry
between the sides.
We have changed the symmetry.
We have not the
completely symmetric sum.
We have a symmetric
summation with phase factors.
So therefore, the phenomenon
is somewhat different.
But we still have superradiant
cascade for the preferred mode.
And the result is that
we have an enhancement
for the most symmetric
for the superradiant
states, which is given by that.
And this is nothing else than
the resonant optical density
of your center.
So in experiments-- many of
them go on in [INAUDIBLE] lab,
where he uses collective
spin and the storage
of single photons in
n atoms, the figure
of [INAUDIBLE] of his samples
is always the optical density,
the number of atoms times lambda
squared times the lengths.
Finally-- and sorry for
keeping you three more
minutes-- the form
of superradiance
which is very important
is Raman superradiance.
We don't have an
excited state where
we put a lot of excitations on,
because the excited state would
be very short lived.
So what we instead do is, we
have Rabi frequency omega 1.
We have a large
[INAUDIBLE] delta.
And then the
spontaneous emission
with the coupling
constant g takes us down
to the excited state.
In the case that the Rabi
frequency is much, much smaller
than delta, we can
eliminate the excited state
from the description.
And what we obtain
is now a system
which has an excited state.
The widths of this
excited state--
this is pretty much the virtual
state here-- is the scattering
rate which is the probability
to excite the atom
is Rabi frequencied
over detuning squared.
That's just perturbation theory.
And then we multiply with
gamma or gamma over 2.
So this is the rate of
spontaneous emission out
of the virtual state.
And from this virtual state,
we go now to the ground state.
And the Rabi frequency,
or the coupling
for this virtual state,
is the original coupling
g between ground
and excited state,
but now pro-rated
by the amplitude
that we have mixed the excited
state into the virtual state.
So therefore, we have now
obtained a superradiant system.
And for instance,
we did experiments
which became classic now
because they are conceptually so
clear-- we took a
Bose-Einstein condensate,
we switched on one strong
of resonant laser beam,
and then we had a system
which was 100% inverted,
because we had no atoms
into the final state.
The final state is a
Bose-Einstein condensate
but with a recoil kick.
So by just having a
Bose-Einstein condensation
and shining this laser light on
it, we had now in this picture
a 100% inverted system, which
is the ideal realization
of a fully inverted Dicky state.
Everything is
completely symmetric,
and then we observed
superradiant emission
of light pulses.
OK.
So this has been the
important realize--
so important experiments have
been done via BECs in my group
and with cold atoms in
with laser code samples
in [INAUDIBLE].
So why is superradiance
so important?
And this my last
statement for this class
and for the semester.
So if you have extended
sample superradiance,
those samples are
no longer coupling
to the electromagnetic field
with the coupling constant g.
The coupling constant
g is now multiplied
by the optical density
of your sample.
And there is a lot of
interest for current research
for quantum computation,
manipulation of photon states,
and all that, to do cavity QED.
And in cavity QED,
we try to have
very good mirrors,
very small mode volume
to have a very, very large g.
But this large g which
we achieve in a cavity,
if you put many
atoms in it, gets
enhanced by the optical density.
So the cavity enhancement and
the superradiant enhancement
is multiplicative.
And often, it's very favorable
for single photon manipulation
if you do Bose.
You getting enhancement form
the cavity and enhancement
due to superradiance.
And the person who has
really pioneered work
along this direction is
[INAUDIBLE] here at MIT.
Anyway, yes, with
five minutes delay,
I finish the chapter
on superradiance.
Well, that's the
end of this course.
Let me thank you for your
active participation.
Sometimes as a lecturer, you
learn as much as the students.
And I think partially based on
your questions and discussions,
this is really true.
I've learned a few new
aspects of atomic physics.
I hope you have
learned something, too.
And good luck in the future.